this toc is still a celebration of the
regions now we're going up against uh
owl versus double it's gonna be a teen
kill match you know what this is gonna
be quite exciting because i'm sure they
know each other like the back of the
hand in each other's hands so let's see
this is gonna be home field advantage
for kuni mitsu though
oh yeah
as we go into the match up
this is what we've been waiting to see
and right now the battle
fight
i gotta say man let's see both of these
players teammates
going at it
who's gonna be able to i mean it's gonna
be clear because you know these guys
have been used to each other they train
with each other at times who's gonna
take that imagine right now we're seeing
outplay way more aggressive than we're
used to seeing
yeah really knowing when to come in and
just reaping that rewards but
double though yeah not pulling any
punches here just uh wanting to be able
to find those openings
playing a little more conservatively but
ow nice punish there and now just trying
to control the last few seconds of this
match punishes the spring kick closes
that one out yup i was like a different
player now he's really going all out
with the offense
and that's i think the biggest change
i've noticed thus far is like al is
ready to just start banging it out right
away against double he's probably used
to fighting against this this particular
lydia in this matchup great block there
with the while standing one one punish
the hopkins
yeah and also double yeah not really
showing that much hopkins but there he
was able to land it nice mid there just
for him to close it out so yeah they are
throwing everything in the kitchen sink
to each other for them to get their spot
at the losers finals
oh man now with the clutch down forward
too he's going to push towards the wall
here
some decent damage goes for the mix-up
afterwards
[Music]
the walk oh my god owl gets the splat
converts it oh my god head towards
though able to convert it and now just
one more chip damage for him to be able
to close this one out nice wake up there
ow gets the third round
and our situational presence of mine is
so good he knew because he was sideways
into attacking uh against lydia he went
for the one two four instead and it
netted him so much extra damage
now speaking of damage double just
showing us how what lydia is capable of
back turn mix-ups oh follow it up on the
the wheel kick nice punish there no wall
and now double
choosing yeah doesn't want to overextend
here he knows al is still a threat with
rage nice block on the low rising two to
take us to the final round
yeah you don't block that on reaction
that's one of those things that you know
from experience that he'll go for the
dash into this big sweep so obviously
the experience showing off in this
matchup here right now double with the
slight lively here let's see what he
does good punish there from owl they're
going back and forth
so far so good on the side of owl
and now double trying to work on a
comeback yeah the red tape will help
them get there
no backing away owl does have the wall
to yeah little there but oh my god the
hot knee from owl
that was such a sick with punish that
that patience there from out it really
showed like you know what he's gonna hop
kick me i'm gonna let him miss and i'm
gonna whip punish that and it's great
stuff good stuff from from out there
that was crazy
yeah and and speaking of like um yeah
those hop kicks right uh lydia one of
her strength is just the recovery on her
moves so the way he was able to punish
those whiffs especially at that last
sequence just shows that he's very
comfortable facing um doubles lydia and
for them to go to final
for them to go to the final round just
shows that they have they know each
other so now they have to pull off
that's the thing with team matches right
they need to they train with each other
now they got to show off the secrets
they gotta they gotta pull something off
for them to solidify their spot losers
finals
yeah sometimes just playing outside of
the box because again you gotta talk
about these guys trained together these
guys have played each other in the past
they've been watching each other play
all day on the stream so of course
you're going to have to kind of change
things up because if you're going to
throw out a move you don't want it to
whiff you don't want it to get blocked
you want to make every move count and
that's really what we've been seeing
from ow from most of today but i mean
obviously it still went down to the last
round could have gone either way
but again these are the moments that you
play for sometimes it comes down to that
one single moment that it'll change the
momentum and go into your favor and
that's what you need that is what you
need
yeah
and double let's see what he'll need um
still sticking with the lydia i'm
assuming and we'll be changing to the
precipice of fate so
again it was it was quite down to the
wire i feel like that's how this match
will end up being so
double needing to just uh yeah try and
figure out the the timing and figure out
like the ways to implore lydia's uh
known tools
all right here we go
again this is a shorter set so this is a
race to two this is the last short set
that we will see in the remainder for
our top four but again
it's coming down to these two very
skilled players and teammates going at
it to see who will be facing off in the
losers finals
hey trying to go for the those make
those stance mix-ups
and two
you can see that ow yeah just gladly
goes for the frost like floats him
couldn't get anything out of it though
and now we see the hopkin come out a
double though
uh oh that was great and you know the
range of the hop kick he knows it so
well he was able to hit it at the max
range and still take that wall carry
even though it does go auto screw it
still has insane carry because of things
like the back three four series
yeah it does yeah just for him to be
able to just find the wall just shows
that lydia's wall game is just on the
next level let's go for that teleport
overhead now we see double get himself
out of that wall situation
oh the mini steps just to get away from
the offense and the red tape he's gonna
go for it again just went for the mid
constantly poking and you know just wait
count on double for just him to swing
big and tried to go for that hop kick
once again how able to punish
the ice this time goes for the back step
afterwards
about even on life for both of these
players but double does have the round
lead let's see if i was going to take a
risk here but he gets grabbed and that
might be it no he has a sliver of life
left
oh my god
rising to the finisher of double
he didn't even have to do while rising
too but he was able to do it and just
put that exclamation point but a counter
hit this is going to hurt because it's
going to do a lot of damage and the wall
carry as well
wow
half health already oh
okay
wow
that's just knowledge from just
constantly facing him three rounds
straight double
yeah from from an evenly matched uh
point now to just three rounds straight
yeah double has definitely made the
adjustments
yeah and you gotta give it up there
because like again that momentum it's
not easy to do especially against
someone that you play with all the time
earlier you know it was a very close
match now we're tied up at 1-1
the question here is how how is al gonna
take it al played much more defensively
and much more stoic in in match number
two however in the first match he was
all about offense all about putting the
pressure on his opponent now
double started blocking a lot of key
things that would have you know
otherwise got him into trouble so i'm
thinking here at least defensively and
and the comfort zone that you know
double is playing in it kind of changed
the the the basis of the matchup between
both of them so i think al maybe has to
start utilizing certain other things
going into the matchup and the thing is
with kuni mitsu
all over all of her lows that get her
into damage situations are huge risks
they're all moves that would get her
launched or they're actually killed
right and
that tells me here that do you think
we're going to see a pick where it goes
to a wallace stage that is my question
are we going to see an open that's a
good counter
that's a good choice or devil's pit no
going to vermillion gay again a pretty
big stage but i i think owl does want to
utilize that wall but you're right when
it comes to the lows of kunimitsu she
does put herself in a really tough spot
that's why our comeback factor is pretty
tough and you know how double like
without rising too just those block
punishes are so on point so al
will have to be able to change things up
and yeah probably to kind of risk more
to gain more of the reward
anyways we're gonna go into this what is
the final matchup between these two
unless they get a double ko please don't
do that to me i don't wanna i don't
wanna leave
i will leave i will leave the commentary
booth if they get a double ko don't
leave me mark i'll come back yeah i'll
come back tomorrow i don't know like
teammates
i'm not ruling it's in my contract oh it
is okay i should have put that in mine
oh no 20 seconds already burnt and now
we see that owl is in the deficit but
trying to fight his way back in this
poking his way in this match
oh man he tried to get him preemptively
with that down forward too right now
slight life lead for double oh he's
gonna have to be careful he's trying to
jump this time counter hit okay the
follow-up and this is going to do a ton
of damage
oh the side wall
picks it up
oh attacked it on with that low and ow
gets the first round so yeah stepping on
the gas a little bit with the offense
has seemed to have paid off but there's
the there's the big low and double ready
with that rising punish
you couldn't see it but i muted myself
and i said a bad word that was crazy
[Laughter]
good on the mute there oh
nice oh it's definitely turning things
up what a low parry that was insane
with his back against the wall he really
read out well there
halfway through the second round double
can he stop the momentum of ow how is
playing out of his mind now risking a
lot
nice dock one more load attack it on
looks like an even match to me
go round number three let's go
back and forth between these two players
and looking at the offense things are
starting to change right now and you
know al was very very aggressive now
he's starting to tighten up what is he
waiting for what is he trying to bait
out of double
we didn't get that set to
oh my god that was so close
double now backed himself up to this
corner
and now we see it try to go for the side
step four followed up oh gets the grab
instead double now has wall advantage
red tape him
he tried to catch him that would have
netted him a positive on hit what's he
going to do here
nice whiplash oh my goodness
you know what a punish by owl collecting
as much as he can double
like just like stepping his way outside
of that wall situation no political
storm gets blocked nice block on the low
following it up with the rage drive oh
the axe kick
wow
fight
surprise surprise two rounds to one
double now on the verge of guaranteeing
himself a spot in our losers final
now needs this round to stay alive
he does cartwheels in without low once
again
risking a lot double you saw i was able
to punish that in previous sequences how
okay
he's attacking in the damage nice walk
there
but double still has that comeback
factor blocks the df2
oh he's gonna have to be careful
mm-hmm
big moment for an hour do you want to
take this the final round
exactly
what's gonna happen oh my god
double
one more but do it follow that up not
enough
ow oh my god oh
double moving on that was so close i
thought we're gonna see final
all right i'm fantasy if it's gonna be
double ko i thought mark man was gonna
do that but no
doubt was close we almost got it
that was that from crowdshow 403 into
the the dome awashi the wheel kick he
was able to close it out that was some
good stuff but man i can't believe
that's what he went for because he bet
it all there that would have been a
launch punish and a death but again it's
sometimes all about the moves that you
don't expect coming that really net you
the positive and for him he was able to
get the win so congratulations to double
uh now moving on